people
are standing up
hello there guys so a new tv spot has
released for the end or tv show which is
releasing on august 31st so we have two
new shots from this trailer which both
involve andorra himself the first shot
is of endor walking through this
scrapyard looking environment but just
because of the flames we can see on the
ground this could be in an environment
which has just witnessed the aftermath
of a battle and then we just have andor
walking through this war-torn
environment on the left side of the
screen here we have a guy that is
salvaging some stuff the next new shot
is of endor again and he's just looking
into the distance and again with both of
these new shots it is hard to deduct
what planet or what environment they are
in it looks like these places and
planets could be two completely new
environments we have never seen before
and what are you guys thoughts on andor
as i said in my previous video and
always my most anticipated star wars
show because everything about it just
looks absolutely spectacular and i
cannot wait to see what this show has in
store for us so far there are two
seasons confirmed both seasons contain
12 episodes each and end or when it
premieres on august 31st will premiere
with not one but two episodes so like
kenobi we have two episodes to look
forward to in the same day anyway that's
pretty much everything about this video
so if you did enjoy please drop a like
subscribe and turn notifications on to
show your support thanks for watching
guys